elaborate on what you said yesterday
you said that we should prioritize
social events that matter and
de-prioritize more trivial ones
in practical terms could you explain
what you meant when it comes to people
thinking for example about their
christmas plans
thank you uh chad so the um
what i i hope what i said
was reasonably clear but i'll try and
phrase it slightly differently and see
if that that helps
you i think everybody can see this is
moving very fast and this is highly
transmissible and the rates are going to
continue to go up
it's a period of the year when lots of
people have got things that really
matter to them family wise also in other
bits of their life
and my point was and i hope this uh i
hope i can reiterate this that um people
want to protect the time that is most
important to them and that does
therefore mean in practice it is
sensible for people to cut down on work
or other
interactions of people including
potentially social ones which are less
important to them so that they they
reduce their chances of catching covid
and indeed reduce their chances of
passing it on i wouldn't want to
say to people they should do a
particular thing they should do this or
they should do that this is about saying
to people look this is a period to
prioritize and that also to be clear was
a message the prime minister also uh
said last night
so just to be a bit more specific dr
nikki kanani
yesterday advised people not to go to
football matches if it was to watch
football do you agree with that
what she was actually saying was if
someone went to a stadium please make it
an opportunity to have a boost and i
think that was a that's a message we
really seriously wanted to get to
but obviously uh we want to get back to
a situation where we're back on a more
normal track and the route to that lies
through the booster program and what she
was saying is we are opening up stadia
over this weekend for boosting and her
positive message as someone very heavily
embedded in the boosting program was
please take your opportunity to get
boosting if that means going to a
stadium that really should be the
priority you're not advising people not
to go to football matches correct
what i'm advising people to do is to
prioritize
if the most important thing to them in
the next 10 days is to go to a football
match that's the priority for them
that's really the point i was trying to
make but prioritize the things that
really matter to you uh but don't uh but
if you wish to do those things and wish
to do so and not end up self-isolating
or unwell at a time you really don't
want to be then you're probably going to
want to do fewer other things
so if you were planning in the the next
week to go to
i don't know four or five social
functions uh your advice would be trying
not to go to perhaps the two or three
that matter least to you
well certainly i mean obviously depend
what other social basically what i'm
saying is that anybody who has something
that really matters to them concentrate
on that thing and then build out from
there rather than just accepting every
invitation and going to every bit of
work in person and this very much
applies also to work situations
certainly our team are way down in terms
of the numbers coming in that's quite
right most other teams are that i know
and that's very sensible government
guidance is work from home if you can
and that absolutely remains the guidance
now
just to be
more specific on something that's going
on a lot at the moment which is
christmas parties and office christmas
parties i think what you're saying is
that if you're one of those people for
whom that kind of party is not essential
as compared to
spending time with your family for
example then that would be a good thing
not to go to
yeah i'm really trying to avoid and
you're trying to make me that i'm still
trying to avoid making other people's
choices for them but i would go on to
say really clearly that i think people
should prioritize what really matters to
them and then cut down on the things
that don't for some people it may be
that what really matters then is going
to the office party fine but i think it
really should be it should be ready for
people to make those choices that's very
clear and and helpful thank you for that
can i just move on to some
more questions about omicron itself and
what we do know and what we don't know
now one of the things that you talked
about that we don't yet
really have
hard data on is the extent
to which vaccines will stop you getting
seriously ill
so so far as i understand it's the
studies seem to show quite a lot of
vaccine escape after two doses but much
less after a third booster dose
could ask do those figures relate to
antibody deterioration and
t cell deterioration or is it just
antibodies
there are two lines of evidence there's
the lab side of things and there's the
clinical side of things
and for all of these and i know you know
this chair but i'm laying it out for
people watching this there are kind of
three things we're interested in the the
ability of the vaccine to stop people
getting infected
uh the ability of the vaccine to stop
people getting severe disease and ending
up in hospital and the ability of the
vaccine to stop people dying and in
general
they get more and more effective as you
go up that line now what we have at the
moment on the lab side is quite a lot of
different labs looking at the antibody
data which is half of the immune system
as you imply and that certainly suggests
that antibody response is much less
effective against this variant than it
was against delta and alpha and the
original wuhan strain
now that doesn't necessarily that that
is like to translate into reduced
ability to reduce the infection
and that is indeed what we're seeing so
the clinical studies are showing that
lots of people are getting re-infected
uh with omicron who previously had been
vaccinated or
had a combination of vaccines and
natural infection so it definitely is
likely to bypass some of the ability to
reduce
reduce infection
what we don't have is very good
t cell studies uh in the same ways we do
they take longer to do for one thing
from the lab side what we don't have is
clinical studies either from south
africa or the uk or anywhere else that
say to us with confidence uh what the
level of protection of two dose of one
dose two doses and a booster dose are on
hospitalization and deaths
now i think most people think on the
positive side we all think that there
will be some preserved
immunity
particularly on the uh the non-antibody
side t cell and other side and therefore
it is likely that the someone who's had
one or two vaccines already will have
some protection and with a booster
considerably more protection against
hospitalization and deaths even though
the protection against uh infection is
less good and the final point i want to
make on the boosters is it does look as
if they restore some of the ability to
actually uh reduce infection probably
quite a lot of it actually at least for
a period of time and so there are um
multiple reasons to get the booster
it will reduce your risk of severity uh
it will reduce probably the risk of
mortality and it almost certainly will
reduce your risk of transmitting and
getting symptomatic disease so we really
want to push the point that boosters is
absolutely critical to this when do you
think we will get good data on uh
hospitalization rates and uh risk of
severe illness and death
i think we'll get some reasonable data
from south africa before we do from the
uk but that will be for two doses
because they haven't got a booster
program in the way that we have yet
and they will probably go first on the
clinical side but there's good data
coming here and i'll ask dr hopkins to
talk about that because uk hsa indeed
specifically droppings itself are
leading on this in terms of the booster
that will take longer obviously because
uh as of uh you know two weeks ago
almost nobody was boosted uh and now
we've got really really good levels in
in the older population uh but we
haven't yet uh got all the way down to
the group which is actually being
infected by um by uh omicron uh susan do
you want to add to uh what i've said
yeah so we have a series of studies that
we have planned and are have the
analysis all ready to run
what we know is that we need about 250
individuals in hospital before we can
make a severity assessment uh compared
to uh delta
and also our vaccine effectiveness
assessment we start running that
assessment when we start having enough
cases who have been admitted to hospital
to do it and then we run it daily
until we have enough power to determine
that the results are effective to
allow us to be basically make um
assessments to release how many omicron
patients do we have in hospital as of
today or yesterday
so the released numbers that we released
yesterday are 15 however we are
constantly working on data linkage to
improve that and we will release new
numbers this afternoon
but the real number will be much bigger
than that that is simply the number who
have proven just to be clear exactly
understood but just to give us all as
members of the public an idea of time
scales are you expecting to have some
reliable data in before christmas in a
week's time or is it going to be uh
january before we really know the answer
to that question
i i think with the earliest that we will
have reliable data is the week between
christmas and new year and probably
early january okay thank you let me move
on to another question if i may um
professor witte which is about
transmissibility now there's been a lot
of discussion about the doubling rate
being
two days or even less than two days
obviously mathematically that would mean
that within two or three weeks the
entire population would be
infected is that what you expect to
happen or would you expect the doubling
rate
to slow down as the
infection progresses
so i think that the um the doubling rate
will slow down for two reasons
um the first is that people are taking
sensible precautions it's very clear
they're taking sensible precautions and
that itself will help to slow the
doubling rate down and what the points
we were making about you know uh
prioritizing the interactions that
matter to most you the government's
advice on working from home they're all
designed to help slow this down
particularly at the beginning to bias
time to get through the boosting and
then at a certain point um the number of
people who are already been infected and
got immunity either from the boosting or
from omicron itself will mean that the
sort of the group of people it can now
infect is getting smaller and that will
also slow it down at a certain point
that reaches a peak i think what we will
see with this and i think we're seeing
it in south africa is that the upswing
will be incredibly fast even if people
are taking more cautious actions as they
are
that will help slow it down but it's
still going to be very fast it'll
probably therefore peak really quite
fast
my anticipation is it may then come down
faster than previous peaks but i
wouldn't want to say that for sure i'm
just saying that that is a possibility
but in terms of where we're going over
the next next couple of weeks the rate
of increase is going to be i think
fairly uh fairly
impressive okay um let's just talk about
that peak for a moment so the london
school of hygiene tropical medicine
which advises sage say they expect
that over the winter months 20 to 30
million brits will be infected with
omicron it'll peak at around 600 000
infections a day around the end of
january hospitalizations between
three and seven thousand a day
is that your central expectation as well
i'm i have to admit that i'm extremely
cautious of uh forward projections on
exponential models um uh and the if the
london school business isn't the
criticism the model to be clear
that the problem is that even a very
small change in the the inputs you put
in leads to a very big difference in
what you get out at the other end and
there are some really critical things we
don't know
we obviously don't know what level it's
going finally to peak we don't know that
yet and we we do not yet know what the
effects in terms of hospitalizations of
two doses of vaccine
of prior infection and of a booster dose
are and there is still debate about you
know could this be a slightly milder
version i don't think it's to the point
of actually triviality but it's just and
all of these are really important so i
i'm very careful and i'm not all the way
through the whole pandemic i've resisted
putting number forward projection
numbers except over a very short time
period where i think it's more reliable
into public domain simply because i
don't think they're reliable and you
can't put enough caveats on them
okay um so but let's look at the numbers
we do know we do know yesterday was the
highest ever
daily
reported level of infections
you said you thought we might end up
because of the time lag
to hospitalizations and deaths we could
end up with a record number of
hospitalizations
at a daily rate as well we don't know
but we we could do that the general view
is that the nhs
starts to really struggle if they have
to cope with more than 4 000
in a day and i think the previous peak
in january was 4500.
do we have to confront the realistic
possibility even likelihood that that
4500 previous
maximum will be exceeded
so i think that uh there are kind of two
there are several different bits to this
and of course we're talking about huge
uncertainties so i don't want to this to
be seen as i'm saying this will happen
i'm just saying there's a range of
possibilities
but certainly the peak of just over four
thousand five hundred and four thousand
five five hundred eighty three to be
exact people admitted at the absolute
peak it is possible
because this is going to be very
concentrated that even if it is milder
because it's concentrated over a short
period of time you could end up with a
higher number than that going into
hospital on a single day that is
entirely possible it may be less than
that but i i'm just saying that is
certainly possible and the whole point
about this is it's going to be really
concentrated in a very short period of
time very possibly
but there are two caveats to that
however
because one of the things that really
matters to the nhs is also how long
people stay
and if for example people stay in
hospital for a shorter period because
they're protected by prior vaccination
that means that the total number could
still be lower even if the peak number
per day is going up is higher so the
peak the total number peak total number
of inpatients
was
about just under forty thousand thirty
nine thousand two hundred fifty three
fifty four other to be exact uh it could
be you could have a higher daily rate
but a lower inpatient rate if there's a
shorter hospitalization obviously you
could go the other way as well and the
other thing is that uh the number going
in to icu could also be quite a bit
lower if uh in addition to protecting
against hospitalization vaccines provide
additional protection against really
severe disease so i think what we
shouldn't assume is that if we got the
same number going in the front door that
necessarily translates into the same uh
numbers in hospital in an icu uh in
some point in the new year okay
so we had that previous peak in january
and
what we did then was we controlled it by
locking down the country and that
brought that
that number down have you advised the
government that we need to be doing more
now than we're currently doing to reduce
the spread of omicron
uh well i i'm going to give a formal
answer and then i'll try and give a
slightly more helpful one but my formal
one is the only formal advice is what
comes from sage on the science side and
that is published and it's very
important that we don't start saying
this is what we said to ministers on
this that the other day there will be a
public inquiry they'll go through those
but other than that the convention isn't
obviously as a distinguished previous
secretary of state you would have
expected the same the advice to
ministers is absolutely uh confidential
but
the what the government is uh has said
and i think what we have all said is to
make really tough uh economic and social
decisions there are some really key bits
of information we do not yet have
and there's a very wide range of
possibilities as to where this could go
some of which are as you imply
uh very difficult for the nhs indeed and
some of which are much less so and we're
getting new information the whole time
so this is being reviewed by the
government the whole time but they got a
clear plan of action ministers have said
i did clear plan of action which is
double you know has two strands one of
which is around uh working from home
plan b things all the things to try and
slow things down at this initial stage
of the upswing and the other really
critically is the booster program but
obviously if the facts change and it
becomes clearer things are heading the
wrong way ministers are always going to
take uh take you know constant reviews
of this well that's what i really wanted
just that's
helpful what i really wanted to
understand is um in terms of setting
expectations i appreciate you can't
uh tell us about every detailed
conversation that you have with the
prime minister but in terms of setting
expectations at the moment uh theater
performances christmas parties football
matches are all going ahead
but if things continue to take a turn
for the worse
we need to be prepared for that to
change is that what you're saying i
think that if it looked as if the
vaccines were less effective than we
were expecting i think that for example
would be a material change to how
ministers viewed the risks going forward
can i just add one risk which is going
to happen irrespective
and that is that because of the
steepness of this
even if this ends up in a situation
where boosters do hold this to a large
degree for a lot of people there's still
a lot of people in the hs so there's not
an nhs point however
a lot of people will simultaneously
fall ill and be unwell isolating or
caring for others at the same time
across the whole economy so that side of
things i also do think we need to take
quite seriously
thank you luciano thank you chair uh
professor whitty you've been very clear
that kovid will be with us for a long
time if not forever in the event of more
variance of concern is it your view that
we will have to continue to live with
reduced social contact deprioritization
in your words for years to come
so i i think what the way that i i'll
try and explain the way that i see this
over kind of a long time period meaning
kind of five year frame because i think
that is a really critical question you
just asked
um if i project forward uh i would
anticipate in a number of years possibly
uh 18 months possibly slightly less but
possibly slightly more that we will have
poly polyvalent vaccines which will
cover a much wider range and we will
probably have several antivirals we've
already got two reasonable ones
and
a variety of other countermeasures
that mean that the great majority and
probably almost all
of the heavy lifting when we get a new
variant unless it's extremely different
uh can be met by medical means because
the because the vaccines have wider
coverage and the antivirals pick up some
of the remaining slack and we've come
from a place where we had absolutely
nothing so everything had to be done by
social uh distancing and all the
destructive things that went with that
right at the beginning where we are at
the moment is in kind of in a transition
period a very large amount of it can be
done by this and this is why the
boosters are so absolutely essential but
we're not quite in the rather safer
haven i expect we will have in a couple
of years time so i don't see this as a a
kind of we're going to have to do this
repeatedly every few months uh situation
i do see this is something where we say
we're in this transition and you know
how we're responding to this variant is
very different to how we would have
responded in a pre-vaccine
uh era so you know that's an example of
how i think things are going to change
but that that change will continue so
potentially that transition period could
last several years is that what you're
saying
i think no i think what will happen is
the risks will gradually decrease over
time it's incremental it's not a sudden
thing but i think each six months will
be better than the last six months how
fast that will be it's always dangerous
to predict science but i think
what's been impressive about this from a
scientific point of view is that
actually my expectations have been
surprised on the upside
all the way through on the science thing
so far we've had faster vaccines faster
clinical trials faster uh faster new
drugs than i would have predicted at the
beginning of the epidemic and in fact
that i did predict with you being the
epidemic so it may you know i'm
my job is to try and give a cautious
central view uh it could be slower than
that but actually there's a possibility
it could be faster than that but i do
see a future which is much less risky
than it is at the moment and as i say
it's less risky now than it was six
months or a year ago yeah so use 4c a
situation where we will be learning to
live with covid as we do with say flu
and that is the longer term plan is that
right
yeah that's that's how we've dealt with
every single major infectious disease
and i think if you look historically uh
one of the things medical science has
been most effective at is every time
it's been faced by a really major
infectious threat we have found a
countermeasure including ones that came
from really uh odd you know the last
really big pandemic very different one
was hiv the approach that we took to
that was obviously completely different
but we now have medical countermeasures
to it
so i do actually think yes i'm in the
future in the long run science will
de-risk this to the point it's not going
to go away as a problem it'll always be
a problem some years will be a big
problem and you know the way i'd i would
see this with kobit at the moment is
this is rather like a kind of high
hairpin bend that it's been put in our
way we were cruising along at a
reasonable speed we've now got to slow
right down we've got to go around it uh
we've got to actually get ourselves back
on track with the boosters and then we
can we can kind of accelerate out again
so that's really and what we hope is
that we'll get less and less needed as
the medical countermeasures mount up
thank you thank you
barbara
thank you chair
i want to ask some questions about
pressures on social care given the link
to nhs capacity and just some points for
context first amanda pritchard and
stephen powers wrote to nhs leaders to
encourage discharge from hospital by
avoiding the need for social care
support through personal health budgets
and hotel beds now reports of hotels
being turned into temporary care
facilities in devon have horrified
patient groups nada ahmed from the
national care association said that
hotels are not configured to deliver
care and question the safety and
well-being of residents if they needed
urgent medical assistance
do you think people can be cared for
safely in hotels and is this a
proportionate measure to take in the
context
so i i want to um
you know start this by saying that
i'm you know i'm not responsible for the
operational side and i don't want to try
and start making out nhs policy on the
hooth
what inevitably you have is a situation
where
as with all emergencies
you're doing the least bad thing that
you can do which is still going to be
far from perfect
and many of the decisions we've had to
take in the health service and the
social care system have been way
you know things we would never want to
do under ordinary circumstances
but they are less bad than the
alternative and if the alternative is a
situation where people are stuck in
hospitals exposed to all the risks of
that and where the hospitals as a result
of that with people who could be
medically discharged there are people
queued up in ambulances outside with uh
with uh life say that's life-savable
conditions but life-threatening
conditions that's clearly even worse
than any of the alternatives but none of
us would see this as a perfect solution
this is a situation you want to have for
ap and of course there are some people
who can be cared for in a hotel setting
where actually it's simply a match just
waiting for them to have a placement so
for some people this is absolutely fine
what the job of the clinicians will be
is to try and make sure as best they can
that the people who are least at risk
are the ones who end up going into
hotels
or similar kinds of
things and the ones who are more at risk
staying
in hospital until such time as they have
a placement which they can move to but
this is this is this is a matter of uh
the perfecting enemy of the good we've
got to just accept this is a very
difficult period uh it was always going
to be difficult omicron has made it even
more difficult
and we are going to end up with some
compromises which are not things we
would normally wish to do
okay
i i think it's quite important that we
that we talk about this and
you know there's a danger of repeating
past mistakes i remember in evidence
that you gave to us last year professor
witty that you said it's clear every
country that has a care sector does not
handle this well the uk is one country
that hasn't handled it well in terms of
the issues in social care
now we said at that point
the inquiry that there are a lot of
things that we've learned and that we
can do a lot better
um but you did say i don't think any of
us would look back on what has happened
in social care and say the ideal advice
was given
how do you think the mistakes of last
year's discharge policy can be avoided
this time around and
importantly if i can just add to that
who is advising ministers on the care
sector and safe discharge because
the advice wasn't very good last year
well i'd like to do i'd like to sharply
uh draw a distinction between the
discharge policy which actually was a
bit more complicated than it sometimes
portrayed and was not what i was talking
about uh i think actually the discharge
policy was in many situations a safe
policy but i can i'm happy to come back
to that but that's old and since that's
an old debate
uh i think we're looking forward to a
new uh set of threats it's just not not
repeating the mistakes that were made
before actually i just wanted to be
clear that i didn't want to kind of yeah
i completely agree so there are several
mistakes that we made um which uh you
know of which i'll just give a couple of
examples which i think we're not doing
now uh the first mistake we made was i
don't think we were fast enough uh on
cutting down on people working between
care settings rather than staying in one
particular one that was absolutely
essential i think we didn't spot the
effects of uh people not having adequate
sick pay uh
until which was an obvious point it's
one of those things is obvious when you
when you see it but actually just
haven't seen how much that was driving
things there are several others which
are uh things which i think we'll need
to come back to but we haven't in my
view repeated those mistakes this time
around we've learned a lot from previous
events the most difficult decision at
the moment for ronakron is how do we
balance
the needs
to allow families and
very close friends to see
people in care and talking particularly
in elderly care against the need to
reduce the risk of this incredibly
infectious infection getting in in
particular before we got everyone
boosted in their immune system
responding that's a really difficult
trade-off because what we don't want is
a situation where over the christmas
period people are left completely alone
but nor do we want to have outbreaks we
can avoid and we're trying to navigate a
route between those two
uh very clear needs that's probably the
most difficult decision at this point in
time
further question that reflects capacity
i don't know how aware you are of the
workforce crisis in social care but
using personal health budgets as has
been suggested as part of discharge
relies on there being staff to be
employed as personal assistants
available to take on that care the
current situation is being described as
the biggest recruitment crisis in social
care that anyone can remember not only
is it the case is that the case but care
providers are reporting that government
funding allocated for the recruitment
crisis is not making its way past local
authorities to them so that you know
take take any uh
temperature on that and it's it's it's
it's very difficult do you think the
very limited capacity and workforce
issues in social care will significantly
limit how many patients can move out of
hospital beds into the community and you
know do we need to think about what
measures can be taken to deal with that
if it is the case because it seems to me
this week that that is the case
well i think i i'm you know i need to be
very careful here my job is to answer
questions that only a doctor can answer
this doesn't strike me as one there's a
doctory question really but i will give
an answer as best i can because it is
very important for the management of the
of the situation there is a very serious
issue with um recruitment into social
care and i think that is widely accepted
and the difficulties of the social care
system
are long-standing and long-standing over
over many years this goes back over more
than one
several administrations so this is not a
this is not a kind of here and now
problem this is a this has been a
long-term issue i you know i think there
have been several recent serious
attempts to look including under indeed
your distinguished chair to look
seriously at what we can do to improve
the situation in social care i don't
think i'm the right person really to
give a view on that i'm just
acknowledging the question you're asking
is a very sensible question i'm just
saying i'm not the right person to
answer it okay thanks
thank you dean russell
thank you chair um
professor we see you all know that this
week has has been quite a debate about
the introduction of the the plan b
measures and
many people voted myself included to
vote those through based on data and on
insights and on predictions that were
given by yourself and and other
colleagues i just wondered if i could
ask you a few questions now on on some
of that data and some of the questions
i've heard since since that time
one of which is
whether you could share the percentage
of positive cases against the number of
tests being reported and whether moving
forward we will begin to see those
trends more public
uh so on positive tests versus test
reported i'm going to turn to dr hopkins
because this is the uk hsa
issue
thank you so we report um in a test nhs
test and trace statistics on a regular
basis the number of tests reported
positive from each of the channels that
are there so home testing channel versus
on-site testing versus
adult social care risk and look at
lateral flow and we can see that there's
a very big variation in those
walk-in testing usually has the highest
test positivity because those people are
symptomatic for example agile social
care has very low positivity because
actually what we're doing there is
testing people who are well regularly
and repeatedly to avoid infections
coming in so that data is produced on a
weekly basis forms and forms part of the
traditional nhs test and trace
statistics
and again we do report the number of
tests performed on a daily basis um on
the coronavirus dashboard and also know
the number of positive individuals and
if i may ask on that so one of one of
the comments that i've heard is that
because we're now testing right down to
children aged five for example that the
the the chances of having a higher rate
of infections is going to go up because
the the sample data is higher is that a
fair fair thing to say or is that um
skewing the data so firstly i mean we
release on our weekly reports age
testing and
rates and also positivity rates by
children of all age groups we have
always tested young children who have
had symptomatic disease
the only change in the um advice that's
come out this week is that daily testing
if you're a contact will go down to as
children as young as five to reduce
transmission in schools
and in terms of um and perhaps if i
could come back to you professor whitty
one of one of the other comments that
i've heard is that people uh are
concerned that we're prioritizing covid
over other things and especially with
with the the uh omicron um variant you
know covered over cancer covered over
other other serious issues what would
you say to that
yeah i think this this is sometimes said
by people who have no understanding of
health at all but i don't think it's
said that anyone
honest and when they say it is usually
because they want to make a political
point um the reality is and if you ask
any doctor working in any part of the
system they will say this that what is
threatening our ability to do cancer
what is threatening our ability to do
all these things is the fact
that so much of the nhs
effort so many of the beds are having to
be put over to covid
and that we're having to work in a less
efficient way because cobit is there
finding a way to manage kovid in a way
that minimizes the impact on everything
else is absolutely central to what we're
trying to do
uh and i will you know in a sense i
completely agree there are multiple
other things in addition to code if we
don't crack covered at the points when
we got big waves as we have now we do
huge damage else elsewhere and the idea
that the lockdowns cause the problems
and things like cancer is a complete
inversion of reality if we had not had
the lockdowns the whole system would
have been in deep deep trouble and the
impact on things like heart attacks and
strokes and all the other things people
must still come forward for when they
have them would have been even worse
than it was so i do want through all of
you to make absolutely clear that's an
inversion of reality that's a excellent
answer thank you maya very last question
it's just i know one of the concerns
i've had through is about uh macron and
the impact on children have we got any
more evidence now about what what impact
there could be that's different from say
the delta variant
that's a really important question at
the very initially some of the south
african data did imply that there might
be a slight increase in um the number of
children getting it compared to previous
waves still nothing like many of the
other infections which are primarily
children inspections of children
actually as the data have gone on in
south africa and for what is worth in
our early experience in the uk we're not
seeing that develop so i think at the
moment my view too early to be sure but
i don't think there's anything that's
saying we should change our advice in
terms of the relative risks for children
now the total number of people infected
with this over a short period is going
to go up so some children a lot of
children will get it and he's very small
number hopefully we'll get into trouble
as a result of it because this is not a
trivial disease
but it is much
i think we would still stick to the view
that this is much milder in children
than in older adults
thank you thank you sarah
thank you chair um professor whittie
i've got two um topics for question one
of them is uh pregnant women and the
other one is new variant so i will get
started straight away in august only
22.2
of pregnant women were vaccinated yet
one in six of the most critically ill
patients are unvaccinated pregnant women
what should the government be doing to
increase the take-up and was it a
mistake to not include pregnant women in
priority vaccination groups sooner
so on the first of those i completely
agree with the point you're making and
and uh
you know the the um
the uptake of vaccination in pregnant
women is depressingly low uh and as you
say uh significant numbers of women have
come to serious harm as a result of this
almost all the women who are in hospital
or in icu
with this are people who have not been
vaccinated so vaccination really
protects pregnant women and pregnancy is
a period of vulnerability i think that
we really should have um uh uh we really
should have um uh made that point even
clearer earlier on this isn't a
government point this is a medical
professional point of course to
obstetricians people like me have said
it i've said it several times publicly i
really my uh
the chief scientist uh here in the
department uh lucy chapel who's an
obstetrician herself said we've all
tried to say this very strongly uh i
think that there are a lot of myths
around this and this is the thing we
really need to take on is we need to say
look it is not true there are increased
risks of this vaccine what is true is
that covid and pregnancy is a dangerous
combination and we absolutely should be
encouraging everybody who is pregnant to
get vaccinated because that helps
protect them
and that is in the long run interests
interests their baby and uh their future
so i absolutely agree it's a serious
problem and everybody should be doing
everything they can to increase that in
terms of the um change of uh emphasis
uh i mean i think jcbi are looking at
this and i hope that they will um give
an answer on that pretty soon
thank you professor whitty i think it's
probably quite shocking given the
statistics and what you've just said
about the importance of women getting
vaccinated pregnant women getting
vaccinated that the jcvi hadn't
prioritized pregnant women sooner i just
wanted to break down a little bit
further so the 22 percent is shockingly
low and it's even lower when you look at
the statistics and ethnicity for black
asian minority ethnic pregnant women
is there any plans to really prioritize
an education program in terms of health
care practitioners as well as pregnant
women and what is going to be done to
increase
that low vaccination rate for pregnant
women as a whole do you know if there
are any plans in the pipeline for it
yeah so there's a really quite strong um
uh
communications push i'm acknowledging
that this is not my area of expertise
but i've seen a lot of activity on this
in a sense there are two things
intersecting on this
there's a really strong communications
push out to make sure that we are much
uh more focused in making sure we get
overall messages on vaccination through
to people from every community in the uk
including ethnic minority communities
and that that is essential we need to
keep on pushing on that it's getting
better uh overall uh but uh it's nowhere
near as good as it should be and there's
a separate thing on pregnancy and then
within that there's a separate thing on
pregnancy in ethnic minority groups and
i know that individual practitioners as
well as
particular places where there are high
concentrations of ethnic minority groups
are doing everything they can to get
this message home
that vaccination in pregnancy is really
important for the safety of mum and
therefore for the long-term safety of
long-term benefits of baby as well thank
you and with the spread of omicron do
you think pregnant women should be
better supported to work from home
or stay at home and financially
supported if they cannot work from home
uh well i i think i you know i'm going
to revert back to a point i made earlier
which is
that's not really a medical question
that i feel i have a particular
expertise to say except the general
point that i would want pregnant women
of course absolutely to be supported uh
medically uh very strongly of which the
most important thing i'll revert back to
your first point is the vaccination okay
thank you and i'll just move on to
new variants is it time to move on from
focusing on just our national vaccine
statistics and more towards a global
vaccination rates regarding the spread
of and slowing the spread of new
variants well i think i i very strongly
believe and i'm very confident that
everybody both both my fellow panelists
and all of you on this committee believe
that we should be maximizing the number
of vaccines available in low and middle
income countries i you know and that is
it's it's a humanitarian need uh it's a
need as fellows fellow global citizens
and actually it's in enlightened
self-interest as well because this is a
problem for everybody wherever there is
an issue so there's absolutely nothing
to be lost and everything to be gained
let me put a butt on that
and the biggest but is that um in africa
and the resource-poor parts of asia
where i had the privilege to work for
much of my early career
there are good vaccination systems for
vaccinating children under five but
there is not a system designed for
vaccinating older adults who are really
the biggest priority everywhere in the
world
and
that is something so we don't we can't
just say here's a crate of vaccines off
you go we've also got to look at
delivery systems so i think we need to
see this as a as a whole system problem
not just as a product problem but i do
basically agree with the thrust of what
you're saying and i don't think
that's controversial incidentally i
think everybody would agree with that
thank you thank you dr luke evans thank
you chair a couple of context setting
questions if that's right uh dr hopkins
first what's the current r value
so the overall or value in the uh that
was reported on the dashboard last week
is between 1 and 1.2 however the uh
it should be noted that there's two
current variants circulating one is
delta which is remaining relatively
stable in number and the other is
omicron which is increasing very rapidly
and with the doubling time of every two
days the ore value for
alma cola is estimated to be much higher
um
very broad brush estimates of between
three and five at the moment thank you
and with regards to that what is the
absolute risk to those vaccinated and
unvaccinated of delta variant
just
what do you mean by unvaccination
vaccinated so for people what's the risk
of mortality for
for those who uh have delta uh avers
those vaccinated we've had two vaccines
and those who had none
so the vaccinated um risk of delta um is
the vaccinations with vaccine
effectiveness reduces that risk of death
by 95 percent uh the the absolute risk
is varies per age if you are over the
age of 70 it is extremely high if you
are under the age of 40 it is extremely
low
less than one in ten thousand so the
risk varies with age and vaccine is the
key to reducing that risk so very
important to get vaccinated
do we know the relative risk yet of
omicron with regards to vaccine and
unvaccinated people
not for severity or for mortality as i
explained we need to have a number of
cases to be able to do that
we do know that the vaccine
effectiveness to reduce symptomatic
disease is lower for omicron than it is
for delta um after uh
two doses of fiber for example um uh to
eight weeks more than eight weeks later
uh your vaccine effectiveness for
symptomatic disease in the community is
about 40 percent um and uh once you've
got boosted that goes up to about 75
percent for omicron
really helpful to get the the context
and why the boosters are so important
turning that to
professor whitty you've talked at the
start
of the very first pandemic when we heard
about it about how
the whole plan is population risk
reduction so washing your hands is easy
to implement and has a big reduction
mask wearing is the next level the next
level
do you have a strategy on each of those
implementations for regarding how much
risk it
it reduces so do we know hand washing
reduces by say 10 percent mass wearing 5
no and i i think
the problem is there's lots of numbers
on these banded about the problem
actually is that really what you have is
different combinations of things you can
do
each win each one of which interacts
differently with the others so if you
just take it in isolation you you know
you would never say and randomize one
group to have a face mask another group
to have hand washing and another group
to open the windows what you're actually
going to say in reality is
do the whole lot
because these all build on one another
and they they change different ones
affect different bits of the wrist so
the hand washing is about things you
might pick up by touching because
someone's coughed on a table or
something whereas opening the windows is
particularly important for anything
that's aerosol for example so i think
what you what you know what we would all
say is all of these are
moderate
uh impact of things
incrementally but if you put them all
together
much larger but do all of them because
they uh they what they help do is they
protect you against different elements
of the risk
uh which are surrounding the droplet the
aerosol the uh the uh family on the on
the side professor you you've beaten me
to it because that's where i was going
because uh i know it's for the ministers
and the prime minister to decide what to
do but how is the data presented over
which combination you put in place for
example we could have chosen to have the
rule of six return we could have gone
into tears again um we could have
actually closed clubs or pubs
how is it decided which uh
constellation comes together
i think the the i in a sense and i i'm
going to simplify what is obviously an
extremely complicated and difficult
process for ministers but i mean the
first layer is okay what are the things
that we can do that have no obvious
downside socially or economically
you know saying to someone wash your
hands put a face mask on open the
windows when you can has absolutely no
downsides why would you not say it so
your first question is can we actually
get get can we get through this just
with those then there are some things
which actually have a bit more uh impact
socially and economically and they've
very much government has to take view on
that because they're having to balance
things next level up is clearly things
like advising working from home as
government has done uh it's not in law
but it is in uh in guidance uh and
things like you must wear a face mask
rather than uh we would really like you
to
and then obviously you then go up a
ladder of intervention each lad each
step of the ladder adds some protection
but as you go up the ladder the impact
on society or the economy gets greater
and the difficult decision for the
ministers is essentially how far up that
ladder at any point in time
should they decide to go and that very
much is the way i would consider that's
very helpful and now we've got the
context of why vaccines are so important
we've got the way in which you can deal
with it for the general population one
of the biggest problems facing us in the
future is the fact that there are about
10 percent of the population who
currently aren't vaccinated and the
current first vaccine rate that to have
your first vaccine is about
two thousand over a seven day average so
we have a problem with society how do we
deal with the ten percent or five
percent whatever it turns out to be of
people who won't get vaccinated given
all the context you've given to all the
other questions and now we know uh about
the importance of the vaccine but for
those five to ten percent
medically what is your sort of response
of how we could deal with that what are
the options that you would present in
front of government
yeah a critical question so i think
there's a very small number of people uh
and they're very noisy but they are very
small who basically due to weird
conspiracy theories and all sorts are
just simply going to get vaccinated
and uh except where they work in places
where there are lots of vulnerable
people uh the view of government is fine
you just got to accept that but of the
10
a very large portion of those just
haven't got around to it and that's
really the people you're addressing your
question to in a sense and i think that
there are basically four things people
want to know
and that we have to do and make sure are
culturally relevant as well and that
doesn't just mean ethnically culturally
i mean making sure even every bit in
society feels that we're talking
directly to them in a way that they feel
uh comfortable with and uh and trust
trusting of first thing is they want to
know that the disease is a big enough
threat but it's actually worth doing
anything at all that's a really critical
thing
secondly they want to know that the
vaccines actually work and on both of
those we have incredibly good evidence
we know that this is a big threat i
don't you know and we know that uh the
vaccines do work the third thing is
they'd want to know that these side
effects are within are in are
proportionate to the benefit that the
vaccine is giving them that one we have
to keep on going at because there are
huge numbers of myths out there not by
ant these are not people who believe
them who are anti-vaxxers the
anti-vaxxers start them
but they're not but the people who
believe them they just read something on
the internet they're worried and they
need to have serious information put to
them and the final thing is we need to
make it convenient convenience makes a
very big difference
i found it very striking when i was last
on the wards that the people who i spoke
to who not had vaccines who were
disproportionately
there unsurprisingly an awful lot of
them said i hadn't got around to it yet
it wasn't that they weren't there were a
few of them you'd meet who just believed
all sorts of nonsense but they the great
majority it was i hadn't got around to
it yet and it's that combination of
making sure that their fears are
correctly and politely and uh
scientifically addressed and we make it
as convenient for them as possible and
my hope is that this huge boosting
campaign that's going on the moment also
gives people an opportunity who've not
had their first vaccine or haven't had
their second one to come back and
actually say look the threat has got
i've gone up again now is a really good
time uh to get my first or second
vaccine and obviously for everybody else
to get it that's really helpful my final
question is to dr wade um one of the
things the cmos have
agreed is to suspend the 15-minute wait
post pfizer for boosters are there any
other things that you are looking at
that may well help the throughput given
how important we've just heard it is to
get those boosters given that
convenience seems to be the main thing
what is government looking at doing
practically from your position that may
well make a difference to making the
booster program as successful as
possible
thanks dr evans i mean you've touched on
one of the really key things there which
is that by suspending the 15 minute
weight and you can get an awful lot more
patience through any given clinic that
applies not just to the very large
vaccine centers um but also i've had the
privilege of working in quite a few
community pharmacies during the booster
campaign it makes a real difference
there because there's really only a
limited number of places that people can
sit to wait so that's that's a great big
plus one i'm not i'm not on the
operational side of the vaccine program
or planning it but there are two key
things from that i think i want to draw
attention to
the first is opening extra very large
booster centers i know that wembley will
be open this weekend um i think i think
the chelsea stadium will also be open
those will help to get sort of numbers
up to get through put
the next though and i think this is
quite important for the points that
professor whitty was just making is the
much smaller senses the much more
convenient sensors the places that
people trust and during the primary
campaign i was lucky to work with a gp
in west london who had opened a um open
devaccine center in a community center
as part of the mosque going to places
that people trust um seeing people who
are community leaders being part of the
planning of the vaccine programme for
their community will also not only help
to increase the number of slots
available but increase the ability for
people to be able to get to a vaccine
center that feels relevant to them
thank you laura trott
thank you chair um professor witty i
just want to go into a bit more detail
from the um chairs questions at the
outset about the link between case
numbers and hospitalizations
obviously with the vaccines we hope
we've broken that link to a very large
extent between
cases and hospitalizations so can you
just take us through where we think we
are in terms of the percentage of
hospitalizations we expect from
omnichrome and how that differs from
delta
thank you so i i mean the very short
version of that is we don't yet know
unfortunately
and i'm going to make an assumption
which i think is safe now
that um
that naturally
omicron is not more dangerous than delta
it may be milder it slightly milder it
may be the same we don't know this is
before vaccination
but let's assume it's roughly the same
now if we compare uh where we were
let's say with the last big wave
not the delta the delta way we just
previously had but the one before that
the infection hospitalization rate for
people 65 or over
uh
for that wave prior to the vaccination
program was about 22 percent so 22
percent of people older people
who got infected would end up in
hospital
after two doses in big vaccination
program
accepting the last points that some
people didn't get vaccinated but overall
that dropped to six percent so six
percent of people
who were infected ended up in hospital
over 65 much lower in younger people to
be clear i'm just talking about older
people here
now the question with omicron is firstly
is it intrinsically
milder and i don't think there's clear
evidence that says it is actually at
this point in time i
there are correctly reports that there
are low hospitalizations in south africa
in the last wave but i'm not sure that
that guarantees its margin maybe we
don't know but that's one possible
question and then the second question is
after you've had two doses of um a
vaccine and then three doses with the
booster at what potential does it reduce
its severity compared to what it would
have been and is that as good as delta
uh it's unlikely it's gonna be better
than delta because it's less
well-matched but let's say is it as good
as delta for severe disease despite not
being so good for infection uh or is it
uh or is there some reduction in that uh
severity and that really is the key
question on what's going to happen for
the health service as a whole what
happens over the next period so i think
it's really critical that we wait for
those data before we we jump into saying
this is what's going to happen but the
worst that would happen would in my view
would be where we were back in the alpha
wave earlier this year
and i think the top end of expectations
would be probably uh for two vaccines
where we are in the six percent with
delta but it may it is it is possible
that with a boost we're better off with
omicron than we are with two vaccines uh
with delta for severe disease i don't
think that's likely for infection but
it's possible but we honestly don't know
the range of possibilities is really
quite wide and that's why it's very
difficult
to make definitive views about where it
where the nhs is going to end up in uh
in the next four weeks
but unless we have a significant change
in terms of the hospitalization rate
with the type of numbers that we're
talking about here with omnichrome
infections
we're looking at some very serious
hospital admissions is that is that fair
to say
uh yes i think you know unless things
all fall so of the things that we know
about
most of them so far have not fallen our
way this has got lots of
lots of antibody changes what at least
one of the drugs we've lost uh we know
that we uh it's less effect effective on
on infection but some critical things we
don't know like severity we don't yet
know for sure we know it's not trivial
but we don't be on that we don't know
and on the effects of
boosted vaccines we don't know if they
all fall our way the numbers will be
less concerning
if they don't all fall our way and so
far we've not been lucky uh in cobid so
i think planning on the bases they will
then the numbers in hospital over a
short period could be very high indeed
potentially and that the big issue here
is they're all going to come in a very
concentrated time this is back to the
chair's original set of questions
you know the same number spread over
three months might be something which is
much easier for the nhs to handle than
a uh the numbers we might see over a
very short period of time so that's
really
a very big issue and i'm afraid if i can
add an additional
point which i think people have just got
to
realize
is that this will also be happening at a
time when a very significant number of
staff are going to be off uh ill
isolating or caring so you're going to
have both the reduction in supply and an
increase in demand
in the health service over a very short
time period and that really is the
reason why we're all taking this
extremely seriously
and in terms of hospital inquire
acquired infections
which we know has been significant
throughout the process of this disease
what more can we do on that front
because this obviously is even more what
seems to be even more infectious than
previous waves that we've seen
yeah we have got a problem here on
infection control i mean we've learned a
lot and i think the infection control is
much much better than it was because
we've learned as we've gone through but
two things unfortunately are going to go
against us this is more infectious than
previous ones it just seems to have an
extraordinary intrinsic ability to
infect
and that's going to make it harder
and then uh the main one of the
mainstays of our um our approach was
vaccination
now vaccination will probably boost your
vaccination will reduce transmission but
it's not going to uh it's not going to
probably take it right down to where it
would have been with booster vaccination
against delta so i think we you know we
will do everything we can within the
health service but i think we can't
claim this we will get away scot-free on
this
even with really good rigorous
approaches to this there will be
hospital outbreaks uh and other health
and social care outbreaks uh we will do
everything we can to minimize them but i
don't want to set people up to fail by
saying no we won't have any we will have
some unfortunately because of these two
factors thank you professor whitty thank
you great clerk
thank you very much indeed uh chair
um professor woody if we reflect back on
the the last 20 months
we've taken different approaches
understandably to trying to
to suppress
the spread of the of the virus
we've had
very significant lockdowns
we've had regional tears
we've had detailed specific restrictions
in the last 10 days the the prime
minister
has urged people to get boosted
and we see cues around the block
you have said and you've repeated it
today that people should prioritize
their social contacts
and we know that they're already doing
that people are withdrawing from some
events
have we reached and are we in a phase
in which broad advice
rather than detailed i think as you put
it should do this shouldn't do that
um
restrictions on people
is that where we are is that is that the
the right way to be thinking about this
now
um
is where we are now
um but uh if we were in a situation
where for example it looked as if the
boosters were not going to be as
effective against their disease and
transmission and we were facing the kind
of situation that we had we were talking
about in the last exchange
then ministers are clearly going to have
to
consider what else needs to be done
and you know i'll go back to this
concept it's a very standard public
health concept to the ladder of
intervention
how far you go up that and the further
you go up it the more damage you're
going to do in other areas and ministers
fully have to balance these this is very
much their uh their prerogative and that
of obviously parliament
but balancing those the bigger the
threat
the further up
you probably were going to have to go
and so what we are is ministers have
made decisions based on what we know at
the moment
if that if the information that comes in
is reassuring that will
tend towards one direction if the
information that comes in is distinctly
not reassuring that will tend to another
and that very much is i think the way
the prime minister and ministers are
looking at this well let's consider the
the optimistic um side of this and um
we get through
omicron
perhaps quicker than we might have
thought and that the spike happens and
we come down it quickly
what would trigger the the exit from the
current
set of restrictions and the advice that
you and others are giving
well i think we've seen um a uh before
um and most most recently in uh summer
of this year a very clear de-escalation
of advice even though at that stage
there was still some residual risk and
we accepted that and we talked through
the logic of that and some people
criticized that
uh
but that was the decision of ministers
and there was perfectly sensible
scientific logic that uh that made that
a reasonable thing to do there were
alternative paths but they chose that
one so ministers are always in a
position where they can uh they can
uh go up and down as the facts change
and that very much is the way that the
approach the ministers are pretty
sensibly taken and as you got on but i i
am really cautious to go back to the
stem of your question
about making policy on the basis that
everything might go right
that uh is not in my view a sensible
basis on which to make decisions
based on the range of possibilities
rather than just assuming everything's
going to form my way from here on in i
think that's always i should always be
cautious of that indeed and that's not
the implication of my question it's to
to consider
the scenario which hopefully at some
point will happen in which we can
de-escalate and
the question is what is likely to
trigger that is it a
fall in the prevalence rates fall in
infections is it reaching a certain
level
of
boosters in the population
is it knowledge
based on
evidence of the severity of omicron what
is likely to to trigger such a a
reconsideration
so i think i think that there are there
are multiple exit points and they really
depend on what happens next it's a very
sensible and good question
it could be you know if absolutely every
bit of news that came in from here on in
we discovered that actually with
boosting and double vaccination and a
milder variant actually this is just not
going to you know
we can de-escalate really quite quickly
this isn't of course a big threat
uh an alternative scenario is that could
be a very sharp wave but the wave
decreases quite quickly afterwards so we
you know have to be significant problems
but for a relatively uh time bound
period
there could at the other end but there
is an exit just it's a longer exit be a
situation where actually uh it's not
until you've got an omicron specific
vaccine uh which
somewhere
based on what the manufacturers say
between four and five months uh and
that's the exit strategy but i think
there's there's so many unknowns at the
moment than saying which of these kinds
of exit strategies i am very confident
as you have implied that there will be
an exit strategy
when it will be
and uh how quickly we will reach it
depends on a lot of factors we currently
don't know and that that that
fundamentally is really where we are at
this point in time will you have the
agility uh to
to de-escalate uh if
if the the results um of the various
factors that you've mentioned
going the right direction
will you be able to intervene and stand
down your advice to to minimize social
contacts for example uh to
advise that the plan b restrictions
should be stood down before the time
that they expire at the end of january
will
are you are you set up to do that
well
you're really clear
because i i think you know this but i
just want to be clear for the record
decisions on anything that involves
those kind of decisions are for
ministers not for me i will give the son
santa big advice sage gives scientific
advice formally with the government's
scientific advisor and uh we give data
ministers take decisions in terms of my
own decision my own advice you know i
i've put more
uh more stringent advice in a sense
advice to the general public uh because
because of omicron uh we had less
stringent advice uh before omicron
arrived it's uh it's not you know
the public want us to keep them safe and
they want us not to at the same time
over egg it at a point where it looks if
things are getting back to a more normal
situation of course people will turn up
the dial and turn down the dial as
necessary and of course there are people
in government rightly who are arguing
for the very strong economic
implications of doing anything more than
we need to and it's always about balance
all the way through this this is about
balance
in terms of the advice in both
directions
you are giving advice directly to the
public um and i don't necessarily
criticize that people are interested in
your views and i think respect your
experience uh and judgement uh on this
you have said you've advised people to
prioritize their social
contacts
um that is advice that peop that you're
giving directly
generally in the past you've made it
made the point to to my committee
that you advise on some of the medical
aspects
and then ministers have to weigh in the
balance the consequences
for society for the economy and come up
with a recommendations that brings the
medical advice with these further
consequences together
if you're giving advice direct to the
public
then that process is not taking place
is it
and therefore how do you
ensure
that it's not
one-sided advice and to go back to my
point will you
have the are you prepared to have the
agility to
uh to
adjust your advice that's out there uh
if as we hope eventually it would be
appropriate to do so
i have i am extremely clear on what i
think the role of uh a an advisor is an
independent advisor and what i consider
the very paramount role of ministers is
but there has always been
from the very beginning the very first
chief medical officer in
1850s chief medical officers have always
given advice to the general public
but but ministers reserved to themselves
rightly
anything to do with the law anything to
do with balancing against the economy
this is advice that i think any
chief medical officer would have given
and i don't i don't actually think that
any minister is feeling i'm treading on
their toes on this one this is my job
but i also consider that questions about
things like further measures
uh those are very much for ministers so
it's drawing the line between those two
uh the expectation is the chief medical
officer and medical advisors will talk
as a doctor
independently and give advice as uh as
long as they don't uh stray beyond in
into the job that is specifically for
ministers thank you for watching thank
you thank you um just one very final
question from me professor whitney about
that advice that you've been giving over
the last day
and the issue of compliance with it
isn't the fundamental problem that
people personally
feel safer now if they've had two or
three jabs but the nhs is actually more
at risk or potentially more at risk
because of the nature of omicron and the
fact we have four million or so
unvaccinated
how do you persuade people who've had
three jabs to be more cautious
i i started the whole pandemic with very
high confidence in the british public's
ability to perceive risk and make really
sensible collective judgments and that
has only strengthened over time so
actually my experience has been all the
way through and
what people do demonstrates this and
indeed polling demonstrates is people
take these things very seriously
they accept that if they have had three
doses of that booster they are at lower
risk but people will still take sensible
precautions uh and you know i'm very
confident people's ability uh to say
look i for the benefit of everyone
around me to the older people uh who i
come into contact with for all of these
things i'm going to be more cautious
over a period these numbers are clearly
going up very very fast
and uh in answer in a sense to both of
your questions it would be very odd to
reduce that advice at a time when the
numbers are sparring up
the time to start considering whether
you're producing is when the numbers are
starting uh reasonably consistently to
come down
and i you know people look at those data
and they think look i want to reduce the
risk everyone around me and for my
family and for myself
and i'm just going to take sensible
precautions at this point in time
sensible and proportionate precautions
thank you well professor witte dr
hopkins doctor waite you've been very
generous with your time we appreciate
you coming this morning uh wishing you
all a safe and happy christmas
thank you very much indeed order order
thank you very much
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended